weight loss is a privilege because it
takes time and it takes money which not
everybody has access to in some
instances if you are very low income it
can be very hard to lose weight and
here's why you work maybe three or four
jobs on your way home you don't have
time to cook so you pick up fast food
and once you get home you have to attend
to your five children and all the money
that you made during that day has to go
to them so you have no time to go and
walk no money to get a gym membership
and you have to resort to fast food
because that's all you can have time for
but what you need to understand is i
don't owe you an excuse in exchange for
my existence nor do i owe you any kind
of weight loss so if i am happy being
fat i can be because fat people aren't
just failed thin people yeah she seems
really happy right she obviously this
woman's very happy just like all these
radicals very very happy she says you
need fancy gym membership to lose weight
you need
you know a delivery service from whole
foods no you don't no you don't what you
do need is discipline
and that's hard and there are different
points in people's lives and they've got
more discipline or less discipline but
did you know how you lose weight you
just eat less that's how how dare you